dort lebt man in freiheit keine maß
keine abstände keine irrsinns regeln wie
schön dann kriegen wir das ja gute frage
das fragen wir uns bei bild ja schon
eine ganze weile das tolle an dänemark
ist ja nicht nur dass es keine regeln
gibt sondern das ist auch überhaupt kein
koma ausnahmezustand gibt es ist ja
nicht so dass dänemark mit die regeln
gelockert und dann ganz abgeschafft hat
und seitdem ist die hölle los aus der
hauptstadt dänemarks aus kopenhagen ja
so sieht freiheit aus und man muss auch
sagen in dänemark sieht die freiheit
auch schon relativ lange so aus also der
freedom day da hat zu den letzten rest
an corinna regeln weggekehrt aber auch
davor bei denen mag viel freier als wir
in deutschland und das obwohl die
impfquote auch nicht so viel höher ist
als unsere ich meine wir wissen ehrlich
gesagt gar nicht wie hoch unsere
impfquote ist weil unser
robert-koch-institut das einfach nicht
sagen kann da sind die daten mal wieder
nicht ganz genau und schwanken um bis zu
fünf prozentpunkte also absoluter
wahnsinn müssen halt leider mit den
zahlen arbeiten die uns geliefert werden
auf die müssen wir dann doch irgendwie
vertrauen auch wenn wir alle wissen seit
beginn dieser corona krise schafft das
robert-koch-institut eben nicht
verlässliche zahlen zu liefern aber
schauen wir mal auf das zahlenmaterial
was wir bekommen im vergleich mit
dänemark und da ist es interessant
beginnen am ersten september da liegt
dänemark bei einer inzidenz von 102 und
deutschland bei 80 am 10 september hat
dänemark dann wir schon besprochen haben
den freedom day ausgerufen und an diesem
tag liegt die inzidenz in denen bei 62
in deutschland bei 89 und trotz des
freedom day sinken dann in dänemark die
zahlen hier wo es richtung herbst
langsam läuft weiter am 23 september bei
37 in deutschland bei 68 und so weiter
und so fort also man sieht dieser
freedom day hat jetzt keine fatalen
folgen gehabt das war kein super special
event danach sind die inzidenz nicht
explodiert und mittlerweile haben wir
eben eine ganz ähnliche impfquote das
war ja damals auch noch das argument aus
deutschland von vielen politikern akku
dänemark hat eine ganz hohe impfquoten
deutschland noch nicht soweit zählt
alles nicht mehr wir sind da längst
gleichgezogen das heißt es gibt keine
objektive begründung mehr für
deutschland zu sagen also das was die
dänen können das können wir noch nicht
nehmen man denkt sich in deutschland
tatsächlich mittlerweile einfach immer
neue begründungen aus wir haben ein ja
eigentlich anderthalb jahre nach dem
motto gelebt wenn unser
gesundheitssystem gefährdet ist dann
brauchen wir regeln nun ist es klar
unser gesundheitssystem ist nicht
gefährdet zumindest nicht durch corona
jetzt hat jens spahn einen satz gesagt
vor einigen tagen den ich davor
eigentlich vermisst habe und zwar ja
auch vor corona waren die krankenhäuser
gelegentlich mal voll ja das ist die
realität und dann kam lothar wille der
lka-chef 100 plötzlich eine ganz neue
begründung für die massnahme aufgestellt
und zwar die grippe den die grippe hat
sehr viel mit corona gemeinsam und
deswegen müsste man schaut aus gronau
und die grippe jetzt nicht
zusammenkommen und beide gleichzeitig
die krankenhäuser belasten deswegen
müsste man die maßnahmen schön mal
laufen lassen bislang galt es ja
eigentlich als markenzeichen der
sogenannten querdenker dass man grippe
und corona vergleicht aber die regierung
macht das jetzt selbst wenn es darum
geht die maßnahmen zu verlängern also
wirklich es weiß niemand mehr wofür wir
das alles machen wofür wie
beispielsweise die masken pflicht haben
da jeder schon die chance hatte sich
impfen zu lassen die meisten menschen
haben das auch getan unser
gesundheitssystem ist nicht durch corona
bedroht aber wir halten noch monatelang
an den regeln fest also gemacht und
pflichten bleibt erstmal bis zum bis zum
frühjahr
[Musik]